the panel that will be focused on today
is an issue of energy in central asia
and we have three great speakers Pauline
Jones the long of Brown University ed ow
of CSIS and Steve Levine who's the
author of a book the probably many of
you have re-read the oil and the glory
and Cathy Nepal me she will be our
moderator will give each of the speakers
about 15 minutes and then hopefully
there'll be some opportunity for the
panelists to speak amongst themselves
and then again we'll take questions from
the audience so please join me in
welcoming Pauline Jones laoang will be
our first speaker thank you thanks Tim
it's a little bit tall for me here um
everything's a little bit tall for me in
fact we'll make it work I'm not going to
be able to see my note so I'm going to
kind of wing this essentially
essentially my I take on this is you
know its central is energy central
Central Asia absolutely but the problem
is the focus has largely been one on
international politics regional level
politics and not so much on the domestic
effects of energy wealth and energy
development strategies on the individual
Central Asian states and so I'm going to
focus more on that and I think the
reason why we haven't focused enough of
our energy no pun intended on the on the
domestic level is that there was an
assumption as of the early 1990s that we
knew the answer right there wasn't any
sort of puzzle or question about what
was going to happen at the domestic
level because of course all of these
five all of these well five petroleum
rich soviet successor states right it's
not just the Central Asian states
there's also Russia and Azerbaijan gotta
throw into the mix are going to follow
the trajectories are naturally
inevitably going to follow the jet
trajectories of their OPEC counterparts
right so they're going to be destined to
follow the same types or adopt the same
types of counterproductive fiscal
policies that doom the OPEC States by
the end of the 1980s to things like
double-digit inflation right collapse
the manufacturing agricultural sector on
and on on high rates of poverty right
high levels of indebtedness right so
there there was no puzzle really there
and we didn't need to pee
into the domestic level and domestic
strategies but I would argue actually I
think at the domestic level Central Asia
has actually provided quite a few
puzzles I'm going to talk about three in
particular the first puzzle actually
speaks to this this is this issue of
whether or not energy wealth per se
would allow us to predict right what the
what the economic performance was going
to look like in the petroleum rich
former Soviet states as opposed to the
petroleum poor former Soviet states
right that in fact if you look at the
ebrd scores these are average scores
from nineteen eighty ninety 2005 just is
what one indicator i could give you
others is the one I've chosen to show
today that what you see is on the face
of it it looks like the energy rich in
blue are doing less well in terms of
their economic performance this is sort
of reform indicators both the pace and
the the degree of economic reform that
has been undergone in each of these
these countries and if you group them by
energy and non energy it appears that
the energy-rich are you're not
performing much less worse much less
worse much worse not performing much for
us as was expected but performing
somewhat worse right if you take out
however the notorious reform laggards
right turkmenistan and uzbekistan
something interesting happens right not
only do the energy-rich former Soviet
countries obviously this is Russia
Kazakhstan and Azerbaijan right the five
minus the to perform not just better but
much better than the non energy former
Soviet countries right so that's
puzzling right that you can't actually
predict perfectly the economic
performance based on energy wealth a
loan right you have to look at something
else and that's something else I argue
at length in a recent book so i'm not
going to go into it too much right now
is the second puzzle i want to turn to
which is that you know contra
expectations that ownership structures
if you want to call them energy
development strategies go right ahead I
call them ownership structures that is
who is actually going to own the rights
to develop these resources and who's
actually going to have the managerial
control about what we do with
once we get them out of the ground how
much we take out of the ground what we
do with them once we take them out of
the ground right on how much we export
degree to which we export there's also a
puzzle here in that contra expectations
not all of the former Soviet states
stuck with what they inherited from the
Soviet Union right state ownership with
control was the state that the ownership
structure under the Soviet Union nor
could you map on perfectly sort of just
by how much investment they needed how
underdeveloped their energy resources
were for example or how difficult their
energy resources were to get out of the
ground what strategy they were going to
adopt right so there's also this this
big surprise i think here at the
domestic level in central asia that not
enough attention has been paid to until
of course my book um conveniently right
um the third puzzle right and maybe i
should say something more a little bit
more about this that these two puzzles
largely come out of the fact that not
just that we haven't focused enough on
you know energy development strategies
at the domestic level because we thought
we knew the answer but the reason we
thought we knew the answers because we
looked around sort of the resource curse
literature the dominant literature on
what happens in resource-rich countries
and we sort of presume that they would
follow the predictions of that
literature which say first that ron ta
states are inevitable right in
resource-rich countries regardless of
ownership structure so all countries are
going to be able to rely on external
rents to the extent that they don't have
to actually generate revenue from within
our countries ie they don't have to tax
their populations and they spend
willy-nilly right they they are
primarily based on distributive
imperatives okay the second assumption
that is often implicit and not explicit
throughout the resource curse literature
but is a very very very important and I
think overlooked assumption is that all
petroleum rich states necessarily adopt
state ownership with control over their
energy sectors okay that the third
puzzle right the third surprise from
central asia i think
also is contra the literature and the
expectations of a literature from the
resource curse which is that somehow
petroleum rich countries are just not
able to recover very quickly or at all
rather from economic crises they just
can't recover from economic crises right
because they're so vested in spending
they can't stop spending there so
heavily indebted that they just get more
indebted and they can't dig themselves
out of crisis they also have
institutional weakness right so that's
another problem that can address
economic crises but you see after the
two thousand most the most recent
financial crisis of 2008 global
financial crisis actually had fairly
quick recovery rates particularly in
Kazakhstan and Uzbekistan I would
contrast this for example with
Azerbaijan which we can talk about later
but you have these um rather quick
recovery rates in Kazakhstan which has
avoided recession is actually bounced
back in 2009 and continues to grow in
2010 and you have this becca stano's
virtually avoided a crisis and of course
most of you are thinking yeah that's
because it never liberalised that was
all it really wasn't connected to the
global economy sure okay fine but it's
also managed to continue to to grow
quite a quite a large pace and to
actually use the increase in its oil
exports and its oil production to offset
some of the non the decline in the non
energy side of things okay so I think
this is the sort of a third puzzle
that's been overlooked by not taking
seriously the differences across the
former Soviet the country is a
particularly Central Asia and the
energy-rich Central Asia and how
differently they've actually gone about
developing their energy sectors and the
different implications if that's had for
their fiscal policies and hence their
abilities to I think recover from
financial crisis right um why is this
right and here's where my notes would be
really nice I'm going to try to sort of
distill a very complicated causal story
into two basic points first the reason
that Kazakhstan has been able to at some
level recover from crisis has to do not
with its current ownership structure
there's actually been a convergence
toward ownership structure ship
structure across the former Soviet Union
particularly in
turkmenistan eric sorry Kazakhstan and
Uzbekistan toward state ownership with
control so going back to these these
these these are differences as of 2005
right after 2005 Kazakhstan actually
adopts s2 and so does Uzbekistan so
they're both sort of converging to the
aza by johnny model if you will but what
happens when kazakhstan adopts private
foreign ownership is that rather than
getting this distributive imperative
right that you get supposedly from the
ronte state literature right where
energy-rich states do not have to tax
our domestic populations and are just
all about spending and showing that the
wealth is being sort of sewed well that
the population is widely benefiting from
the distribution of oil rents and so
it's done this very ostentatious way and
this very often wasteful way and
politically motivated rather than
economically rational way right in and
that's what you get under public
ownership under private ownership where
either the private actor is a foreign
oil company this is of course these are
theories and hypotheses that I'm talking
about theoretically where you have
private owners whether their domestic or
their foreign the state has less of a
distributive imperative in terms of
showing off by are showing its ability
to manage the oil wealth properly by by
spending it and more of an extractive
pair imperative that is that I need to
show I'm doing my best buy the I'm doing
right by the population right as a state
leader by showing that I can extract
from foreign investors right and making
this a very explicit part of policy and
one of the things I've done in my book
is sort of track over time the speeches
and and the sorts of references that are
made to foreign investors and taxation
of foreign investors and and looking at
that as an indicator of this
particularly in Kazakhstan and
Azerbaijan as well so there's much more
of an extract to compare an extractive
comparative on the part of the state
than a distributive imperative and what
this is done in Kazakhstan here's the
punch line what this is enabled
Kazakhstan to do is to save rather than
spend right the majority of its Quinn
actually the majority of its windfalls
I've asked a good chunk of its windfalls
right if you compare sort of what
Kazakhstan is taken in to
it's actually save set aside and it's
oil fund that it get created in in two
thousand for example right and again
there are other indicators of this it's
just the nicest one it also is my sort
of tribute to Halloween I like the
colors yeah so um is that in terms of
what as a rush on another kind of taken
in both relative and absolute terms
Kazakhstan has saved a much greater
portion of that of those revenues those
one falls in Azerbaijan and what going
back to this idea of recovery right the
recovery what that's allowed kazakhstan
to do is essentially use the oil fund as
intended which is to use it as a
stabilization fund to stabilize revenues
that have continued to spend at lower
rates that more modest rates and for
example Azerbaijan's done right through
the global recession right again not the
only thing but I'm oversimplifying for
the for the purposes of it of the
presentation so what about let's see
what about uh who's Becca Stan
Uzbekistan certainly follows the more
the model of public ownership right as I
said it started with an s one state
ownership with control its moved towards
Dan ownership without control as its
brought in foreign investors but it's
had under public ownership definitely
more of a distributive imperative right
but nothing close to what Turkmenistan
has done I mean Turkmenistan is sort of
the ranch a state on steroids right it's
your model for if you want to look at
what can happen right with you know
energy wealth run amok you look at a
place like Turkmenistan or near Nigeria
or right it's one of the poster child's
poster children right um but Uzbekistan
is actually a much more modest version
and I would argue that the reason is
becca stan is a much more modest version
is that is Becca stands managed to slow
its growth right it's managed to slow
the development of its energy sector and
it's done this very very consciously
very consciously and by slowing its
growth that's done a couple of things
one is that it's reduced societal
expectations about the degree to which
the state should be distributing oil
revenue and sort of these very
ostentatious ways and he's very sort of
overly generous ways let's say right by
financing all sorts of things like
you know free free everything public
transportation I mean they've been price
controls for sure in Uzbekistan but
nothing on par with what trick medicine
is done certainly nothing on par with
the types of public works projects that
Turkmenistan's engaged in right or the
types of stealing straight off stealing
of oil revenues that's happened in
Turkmenistan case but the key here is
that Uzbekistan has been able to slow
down and for all the 1990s in fact up
until the mid-2000s really put on hold
the development of energy sector right
which is a very very rare outcome right
and it's done this deliberately it's not
because foreign investors weren't
interested right it's not for any of
those reasons that people have have
raised but rather it's it's part of its
conscious development strategy to
utilize its cotton revenues first and to
gain energy self-sufficiency right and
then once doing that to support its own
industry through import substitution
industrialization right so if both the
Kazakhstan and the Uzbekistan case what
happens when the financial crisis hits
in 2008 is that they have surplus
revenue that comes directly from the
fact that they've had these very managed
controlled modest types of spending
programs despite all expectations of the
contrary about what it is that energy
rich states tend to do with their wealth
they haven't they haven't wasted all but
they haven't squandered their wealth
right and as a result they I also
haven't haven't experienced the Dutch
disease that most expected them to to
experience I said that Kazakhstan has
weathered the financial crisis well
because it's been able to stabilize
right its revenue stream uzbekistan's
whether the crisis well because it's
been able to get engage in a china style
stimulus package right not a deficit
spending like we've done the united
states right and not a budget slashing
like they've done in britain but rather
a stimulus package that is financed by
oil revenue which had been set aside
right and so they've been able to do
things like raise public and private
investment levels by thirty percent
right during a global recession which is
pretty impressive okay I won't talk in
the interest of time about the role of
foreign investors except to say going
forward
right here whether or not this type of
recovery is a short or long-term type of
recovery right is this something that
further looks good in 2009 2010 but is
going to start to look bad we see
Azerbaijan for example starting to
plummet and there are good reasons for
that which I can talk about later if
people are interested but how does this
relate to the foreign investors side of
things that I haven't talked so much
about well here's the deal with foreign
investors right in order for resource
development to go well right particular
in the 1990s countries need to be able
to attract the right kinds of foreign
investors the problem is that the right
kind of foreign investors are not always
the types that states want right the
right kind of foreign investors least in
my mind are those that can resist
effectively resist something called the
obsolescent bargain this idea that host
governments immediately after you sign a
contract are going to want to renege on
the terms of that contract right or what
other people call wrongly I think
resource nationalism so you need foreign
investors actually resist that right so
the state doesn't see them is just this
cash cow and therefore doesn't develop
its own domestic economy as an
alternative to the oil sector right but
you also need foreign investors who are
strongly committed to csr and believe it
or not which is corporate social
responsibility I know it's a dirty word
for summer dirty term for some but it's
real and it's real for some companies
and not so real for others it's
certainly not real for the types of
companies that have dominated the types
of foreign Cummings that have dominated
Kazakhstan both under private foreign
ownership and under now under state
ownership without control nor is it the
type of foreign investor that now
dominates Uzbekistan's oil sector and
this is a big problem right chevron and
kazakhstan is not a pro cs our company
it's only recently signed on or
encouraged kazakhstan to sign on dity
and contrast at BP and Azerbaijan Luke
oil and gas prompt certainly not pro csr
in Uzbekistan and so if we think about
whether it's going to be a short-term or
long-term recovery two things need to
happen one the right kinds of foreign
investors need to enter into the
equation and two there needs to be more
engagement of the private sector and
this is something that's very very
unlikely to happen in Uzbekistan but has
already happened in Kazakhstan under the
prior ownership structure of private
foreign ownership thank you i'm going to
stop there because i'm at 15 minutes
Thank You Kathy um the few of you who
know me in this audience know that I'm a
long recovering or in gas industry
person so unlike the previous panel
where you have people dealing at a very
high level for both policy and academia
the 30,000 foot level or Jason who was
on the ground and Laura who was in the
weeds at least according to her I'm
actually going to drill down a bit on
the subject Oh pun intended by the way
and and talk about a central asia energy
from really a in the international
industry point of view and and i guess
one reason i accepted the speaking
opportunity from tim and alex is the
provocative title that they came up with
is just how central is central asia my
initial reaction was that it is about as
central as Central America and the
Central African Republic uh unless
you're from the Orang gas sector and and
and and that's why I put up a map if you
think of Central Asia is really
belonging to the greater Middle East are
then there is no debate at all that
Central Asia is central because the
Persian Gulf is certainly central and
and to the international oil and gas
world and I would like to do a little
bit of what Tom did earlier this morning
in looking at how the landscape has
changed since the collapse of the Soviet
Union
in the 1990s the the bargain for the
industry entering into Central Asia was
quite clear here are these in the newly
independent states with no capacity to
exploit the resources they have whether
you're talking about Azerbaijan offshore
where the Soviets had not did not have
the technology to develop the fields
that they discovered or in Kazakhstan
where the Soviets had the biggest
blowout I that in living memory in
tankies where that the well continue to
be on fire for a year and a half you
think macondo well was bad you could
have seen that blowout if you were on
the moon it was it was such a large blow
out the the resources in Kazakhstan were
deep was very difficult to extract the
Soviets didn't have the capability so
for the industry very little exploration
risk development risk maybe a transit
risks but it was a great opportunity for
world-class plays in the area of the
world that they were previously closed
from working in arm and there was an
implicit political bargain as well both
in terms of the American government
looking at wanting to know begin to put
put a flag in the embassies in this part
of the world or what are the resources
that they have to sustain their
political sovereignty and economic
viability over time or in gas is clearly
have to be part of that equation not the
only thing but even for the country's
the leaks in the region if you look at
the way hi dolly have put together the a
IOC consortium it was almost like he'd
look at it he got a jig national
geographic map of the world and and and
said I need flags from
we needed we need Norwegians British
Americans Japanese whoever and it was a
cobbled-together consortium ah to a give
implicit support internationally to what
was a fledging country but that was so
last century rain and this bargain that
seemed very explicit and clear in the
1990s it's no longer so clear today tens
of billions of dollars of investments
have been sunk in Oran gas in this part
of the world deals that look good when
oil prices were twenty dollars doesn't
look so good to the host government
anymore when oil prices are raging for
up in in the last few years I mean still
at eighty dollar today very high by
historical standards elites who didn't
know whether they could sustain them
their viability is independent countries
and not have had 20 years where you know
they're the sense of confidence is very
different for the industry there's been
very little exploration success by the
way I mean the with the exception of
shock deniz gas field offshore
azerbaijan and kasia gan offshore
kazakhstan expiration have primarily
been a disappointment all the
developments that you read about our
farm existing soviet x discoveries that
the Soviets didn't know how to develop
so you know the kind of bargain that
seemed very very clear or balanced in
the 1990s in today's world doesn't look
the same anymore and pauline mentioned
didn't have a chance to get into but the
kind of creeping obsolescent bargain
it's appearing in this region from
industry standpoint contractual terms
that you thought were good for 40 years
didn't look so certain anymore in places
like Kazakhstan and Azerbaijan
you look at oil and gas you have to
always go have to look at the facts
which are important and the I'm not
going to go through these slides which
the organizers can put on the website if
you choose but I put Russia and Iran
into the picture to give you some
context and not only because they are
littoral states of the Caspian of course
which is a more meaningful term for the
oil and gas industry than Central Asia
but you look at the resources that we're
talking about the production levels that
we're talking about all the countries
that that we mentioned does not add up
to a Iran nevermind a a Russia in terms
of production certainly does not amount
to it Iran in terms of reserves the last
column for those of you who think that
I'm just throwing some some funny
numbers in there is reserved production
ratio which is if you add if you divide
annual production against what is no
improvement reserves you get a ratio
that tells you approximately how many
years of reserve life that country has
its a moving number but it gives you a
relative measure of how these countries
compare this is the situation for oil
and this is a situation for gas once
again compare these countries this is
not the Persian Gulf it may be in North
Sea in relative terms in the world
international oil and gas world but it's
not the Persian Gulf for sure if you
look at these numbers so what has
happened then you have now states that
have been independent for 20 years there
they have national oil companies that
are both from an industry point of view
instrument of state policy as regulators
but they're also potential competitors
and these companies have international
ambitions if you look
you know kazmunaigas owning a refinery
in Romania owning ports in in Georgia
sokar talking about refineries in Turkey
and spreading their wings
internationally turkmenistan is always
the exception to the rule in just about
everything I guess but but also in the
oil and gas world and what happens there
is an interesting question even more
what close to three years after neo-sovs
death not much has changed yet the other
way the landscape has changed of course
is there Russia which was on his back in
the 1990s is back in the region and back
in a very very great way I can't
remember and maybe it was Alex mentioned
a great game which is a terrible analogy
which I think you would agree with but
but I I always say to people if this is
a great game we have to remember we are
the away team and the home team's back
right the regional powers are back in a
very very big way and they have distinct
advantages in terms of cultural affinity
speaking the same language literally as
well as elite connections and and and
and a sense of proprietary interests in
the region is also quite strong people
love to talk about pipelines in this
part of the world I don't know why when
I first got into the business business
pipelines were just about the most
boring thing you could do in the oil and
gas industry for this part of the world
it seemed to be very very exciting and
of course for Caspian export routes
Russia continues to dominate in very
very important ways there have been
newly Western funded pipelines that
you've read about what is the Caspian
pipeline consortium or the
baku-tbilisi-ceyhan pipeline but they
are also important new routes
to China which completed a oral pipeline
all the way to western kazakhstan where
the big oil is as well as a gas pipeline
from Turkmenistan through respect to
Stan and Kazakhstan into China it's very
very confusing one thing we know is that
the distances are great there's the
pipeline system that we're working with
in the Caspian region so the economic
hurdles are also tremendous so it's so
confusing i'm going to try to be confuse
it for you in a minute in my
simple-minded oil and gas guy point of
view a pipelines are notoriously
difficult to develop and this is true if
you're talking about the Alaskan the
alyeska pipeline seven to eight years
one state one country from the beginning
to the end and so you know it takes a
long time I always tell my foreign
policy colleagues that this is an
extremely clumsy foreign policy tool you
think you can use pipelines no don't
don't expect to have any results for
five to ten years right and and and
that's just reality and natural gas and
crude oil pipelines are very very
different and we can get into why in the
Q&A I don't want to spend too much of
the panel's time talking about it but
when you when people say that a gas
pipeline can be developed the same way
as an oil pipeline they don't know what
they're talking about right remote gasp
pipelines do not get built until you
have not only a secure supply but it's
secure offtake consumers right we've
only been waiting for the Alaskan gas
pipeline to the lower 48 for 30 years
and and then this is not an accident and
financing who's going to pay is the way
the risks and rewards are distributed so
from my point of view the keys
indicator of the likelihood of pipelines
it says this was the commercial champion
for the project and that's a commercial
champion both have the capability as
well as sufficient economic stake to
want to make the pipeline project work
and if I see commercial champions who do
not have either one of those I start to
poopoo the pipeline project as some of
the people from Washington know that I
do on a regular basis and everyone wants
diversity of supply who doesn't want
diversity supply from industry
standpoint question is who pays right
for diversity of supply from industry
standpoint diversity comes with volume
you don't build an extra pipeline just
in case because it is a five to ten dot
billion dollar bet and and so unless
governments are ready to step in and
build it as sort of the Chinese did ah
then then there there is no no one
willing to step up and pay for diversity
of supply no matter how beneficial that
might seem to people the other thing
that that's happening as i have already
intimated is that the their new players
in the caspian and the question to ask
is maybe whether the major international
or company error is really over that the
no BP being the pioneer and I so by Jean
and Chevron being the pioneer in
Kazakhstan that period is over because
the big plays have not been very
available or easy to develop in the case
of casa con but that doesn't mean that
there isn't room for regional national
or companies that doesn't mean that
there aren't room for emerging national
oil companies from Asia that doesn't
mean that there aren't enough room for
independence part of the oil and gas
industry that have a different measure
of success they don't need the big play
to have success the question remains
what
Vincent turkmenistan in terms of
long-term development and I would
suggest to you what happens in cash Egon
will have a major major factor casa con
is it's the big play that can build a
third major pipeline if they are allowed
to go ahead but look this is a project
that have spent twenty billion dollars
or so and not a dime back in return yeah
right it is highly questionable at this
point economically whether there would
be a second phase of cash agon after
early oil contract turns would have to
be renegotiated the contract the length
of the contract we have been
renegotiated if we're going to achieve
the kind of volume that cash Egon is
geologically capable of doing which is
maybe 11 and a half million barrels per
day are it really important the oil view
so we we have new challenges and
therefore what are the new rules well we
don't know and that's that's part of the
problem except that we need and we know
the conditions are there that would
require players to adapt to the new
environment the impact of the world
market I would submit that it's a lot
more realistic today than it was in the
1990s when there was a lot more hike
about what the Caspian actually mean
there are a lot of wild cards someone
said Black Swan well you know there are
lots of wild cards in this part of the
world including I think for the oil and
gas producing countries the key question
of political secession what happens
after naza by of what happens after they
leave family you know would there ever
be a time after the earlier family since
the grandson's name is also high dog no
not an accident right and what are
American national interests in this
context and and this is my personal list
not everyone agrees to this i think you
know from the beginning we
have an interest to make sure that this
part of the world doesn't become someone
else's backyard again whether it is
Russia or China or wherever we would
like these countries to have continued
to have political sovereignty which
implies economic independence as well we
are the largest oil and gas consumer in
the world the United States so anytime
this incremental supply that comes on
that's good for us whether that or ever
reaches our Shore not doesn't really
matter all things being equal we would
like to support exxon mobil and chevron
in their commercial activities but that
ranks a lot lower in my mind in terms of
u.s. national interests and way way down
there is european supply security i
would submit to you let the Europeans
worry about European supply security and
and there have been times when sometimes
American policymakers flip might the
order but that's just my personal list
not always their dare list and the last
question I would leave you with is
whether we are looking at the dawning of
a new era that Tom already had referred
to earlier this is the picture of the
completion of the Turkmenistan to China
gas pipe blind inauguration ceremony and
everyone's verada recognizable all the
presidents in the both the transit
states as well as producing country as
well as the country that paid for it
except for mr. karima who always seem to
have his back turn against us thank you
very much
good morning good morning when I first
when i first started living in central
asia in 1992 one of the very hard things
was to find anybody who was looking at
the whole region as a region the five
republics of central asia and then the
three republics of the caucuses I just
wanted to say that because what a
pleasure it is today to here to be with
these to be with this panel to hear the
previous panel and it really learned a
lot myself when I when I heard the name
of the of the conference today how
central is Central Asia there seems to
be and when when people study Central
Asia people who do study people who are
oil people or policymakers there's
almost an apology implied in there if
Central Asia is not the central place in
the world it's not worth being it it's
not worth doing anything up and and I
just wanted to say that just that
definition of terms is very important no
central asia is not the central place in
the world but it is a central place and
so i wanted to talk about that today and
say why it is first so why is central
asia an important place because it is
that's the first the first it sounds
flip it sounds glib but think of central
asia as other speakers have today in in
the broader context inc
food and you must include Pakistan
Afghanistan all of Central Asia and
people can take it broader from there
before I was based in central asia i was
based in pakistan starting in 1988 I've
been watching it since then every single
year without fail when I lived there
it's and until now at least one time
every year Pakistan becomes the most
important place on the earth either
there's been a missile strike a coup a
threatened war with India a terrorist
strike in Africa or the United States
the overthrow of a government there's
always something and i was i was
interested that Tom Simmons is here
today he can he can tell you when he was
the ambassador to Pakistan what the
price was when the United States after
the withdrawal of Soviet troops from
Afghanistan withdrew withdrew with drew
us aid money with withdrew its attention
from Afghanistan and Pakistan the United
States takes its eye off of that region
to its peril minerals minerals menara
metals oil this goes without saying one
one big reason why that region is
important maybe the central reason
reason as ed was pointing out is that
there is a ton of minerals there and
incidentally the latest concern of
strategists is rare earth metals
Kazakhstan has has rare earth metals and
and exploration for that will will begin
soon it does not matter the map that ed
I'm going to argue with you the map that
Ed raised that set for the first time
Central Asia doesn't have the same
resources as the Persian Gulf all right
it still has them it still has them and
that's in that that's an important thing
and the last the last item is central
asia wants to engage with the united
states it wants to engage with the West
leader by leader whether it's karima of
Kazakhstan otunba avah whomever even if
they may cause us headaches and grief
they do want to engage with the West
that makes it a place that we want to be
so does that demand a great game that's
what I want to talk about today this
term great game I'm going to make a
defense of the great game basically all
right the great game gets when when the
great game is voice and just think back
today each time this term there's a
snark in the term and uh and we're not
playing the great game who would ever
think of playing the great game and we
oughtn't be playing the great game we
have been playing the great game we've
been playing it since we got into the
into the region and I want to explain
that and we ought to keep playing it
first the the important thing is to
define what is the great game so you
know early early on one of the one of
the rejectionists theories about the
great game we're not playing the great
game because there is this absolutist
definition approach to it you know it's
not Britain it's not Russia it's not the
tournament of shadows therefore it's not
the great game well let's be a little
bit more creative about this
one one of the other objections to the
great game we don't play zero-sum games
isn't zero-sum isn't that distasteful to
be zero sum okay why was the United
States why is the United States in
central asia and the caucuses and why is
Russia there Russia is playing a
zero-sum game because Russia it's it's
own backyard it has been for a very long
time it wants its influence it wants
what it wants when it wants it wives of
the United States there is the United
States really in Central Asia and the
caucuses for hegemonic reasons is the US
seeking influence with a with a capital
I in Central Asia and the caucuses is it
seeking to be the dominant player in
this region the answer to all those
questions in my view is no therefore the
u.s. is not playing a zero-sum game it
never has sought to play a zero-sum game
but it's playing the great game and and
so what is that great game been from the
beginning of the 90s the middle of the
early middle 90s until now it's been
pipelines and what what are the purpose
of the pipelines in that era you know
happiness is multiple pipelines this is
a bumper sticker you know no to flash
man this is strobe talbots we're not
doing flash mint and then finally you
know we're not we're not playing the
great game that whole policy was meant
to to to dilute and and remove Russia as
a monopoly player in Central Asia and
the caucuses no one likes to say that
they didn't like to say it then they
wouldn't say it then but that's what it
was and that's what it is what if Russia
had and continues to have to
a certain degree monopoly control over
energy exports from that region which
translates into economic control which
translates into political control and
then you remove that monopoly that's
that well Russia sees that as a zero-sum
game that is playing the great game so I
reject the great game rejectionists okay
so i want to but let's take this a
little bit further why do I think that
we should continue why do I think we are
playing continue to play the great game
why should we continue it and how the
great game has changed the US has lost
some of its well a lot of its
wherewithal because of the financial
crisis because of fighting two wars so
the great game has changed into the
great proxy game this is the great game
we are playing although we don't know it
and we ought to be playing and what does
that mean it means that there are other
players on the ground who are doing
stuff that is in our interest that that
that that constitutes the execution of
primary US policies in that region we
should be aware of that and in and
either quietly encourage it or just
don't say anything to to to spill that
trouble so what what do I mean pipelines
so the the China pipeline the
Turkmenistan China pipeline was just was
has been mentioned a couple of times
today what has what has the the ultimate
instrument of US policy been in that
region the way of getting Russia out of
the way the way of doing that by
providing
and political independence for these
Republic's it is an independent channel
independent oil and gas pipelines what
is this pipeline two independent that's
a u.s. pipeline built by China that's US
strategic interest that pipeline exists
stop going to Turkmenistan and bugging
Berdimuhamedov about Nabucco the
policies there they that that check that
box and I agree with that I wanted to
throw out there these Republic's to one
degree or another were and are helpless
on the international stage they needed
the United States to help get the Baku
jahan pipeline build and some of these
others Europe is not helpless we don't
need to be in the Nabucco game she get
this this is we're overstretched we have
other things to do stop pushing nabucco
we can help those half dozen East
European republics states that are in
trouble one hundred percent reliant on
gas prom we can help them with
interconnectors LNG supplies but but to
tell dick morningstar to you know go
back to California we don't you know we
don't it's a nice guy but there's no job
for him there Massachusetts thanks Tom
all right Iran there's been there's been
some angst over the bags of money the
so-called bags of money the that Iran
has been delivering bags of money to
Karzai right alert the media thanks us
delivers bags of money what what is the
US what is the u.s. doing in Afghanistan
the US was there originally because of
Islamic expansion
that was al Qaeda we are no longer there
for that reason we're there one auto
pilot and and two because we've extended
our our policy now we want to stop the
Taliban having taken our eye off the
ball allow the Taliban to regroup and
research we want to stop it we're not
going to be able to stop them however
Iran is a natural balancing force
against the Taliban and you know we
don't have to be in the same room with
Ahmadinejad to say attaboy I think we
should stay quiet about the bags of
money that's a good thing and then and
then lastly does Russia have a role does
Russia yes Russia is Russia a proxy for
the United States it is it is in some in
some cases in some ways I'll leave that
for for us on the panel to discuss but I
think we ought to look in the same way
of the the great proxy game we should
look at Russia to as a as a player who
can with with us not having to expend
more effort more money to accomplishing
some of the goals that are primary parts
of the reason that we're there thank
um I'm on now right I'm my presence on
this panel I think shows two things that
being director of the Harriman Institute
for some years makes you qualified to
moderate anything as i think tim has
probably figured out and also it doesn't
teach you a determined microphones and
since my expertise in energy in Central
Asia is largely confined to having
attended earlier versions of this
conference and also two trips to
Turkmenistan where ed challenge I met I
been reluctant to actually moderate more
than to ask the panel to respond to one
another and also been open for questions
the audience but one of the advantages
of being a literature specialist that I
occasionally exploit on panels like this
is to ask naive questions and as I
listened to the discussion here and
about how central Central Asia but but
also that they to me the underlying
question there at which I think you all
addressed is how central Central Asia to
the United States um then the last night
Eve Lee the question of values comes up
and also especially having you know been
working or trying to work with education
reform and Turkmenistan and having had
at least one wonderful Turkmen student
here at Columbia and you know listening
to what and had to say about the you
know one of the issues of people in the
region still being more comfortable in
terms of language and a common shared
history and culture and dealing with
them how is there is there any
possibility that this oldest energy
money somehow someway will will stop
being go over to marble buildings that
are really beautiful and uninhabited in
the center of ashgabat and elsewhere and
it actually might filter down and that
that might translate somehow into values
that would make it easier for us to
communicate with the people in the
region let me try to begin to address
the question Kathy and then I like to
pick up Steve's point about the great
game I i was just in baku a couple weeks
ago and and i think when you go to baku
or istana today and and compare it with
when these i first saw this part of the
world in the early 1990s you are struck
by the talent of the young people that
there are in those countries one of the
things that the government's have really
done a quite a good job on is the the
kind of education programs including
exchange programs abroad and you find
highly educated professional young is
Aries and cos ox who speak our language
as opposed to their parents language
speaking figuratively and and I think
that's an extremely good sign and and
it's a way that we often underestimate
in terms of the transfer of American
values whether that's that's political
values commercial values economic values
cultural values and so on and so we have
a lot more influence I think that then
we did before and this is all to the
good and in terms of long-term
development of the region on the great
game though I can't resist I have mixed
feelings about the great game first of
all it's very good for my second career
because you know who wants to be an
expert on the small game right you know
it gets me invited to speak to teach and
and and so on but from an industry
standpoint the problem of being in a
part of the world where there is a great
game going on
is that industry thinks it's the fox
being chased by a bunch of bloody
government hounds right though it is a
victim often of the sword of instability
this sort of rent extraction ah yeah you
know I know it's hard to feel sorry for
Chevron Exxon Mobil but try ah and when
that happens what it frees this
investment is what happens when you are
seen as working in a part of the world
where there is this great power rivalry
and and so as I said I have mixed
feelings about it yeah so a great game
if it is a nonzero-sum if its value
added might be a good thing but there's
also a possibility a great game is
valued it is subtracts value from
otherwise would be a healthy situation
so there is a negative aspect to the
great game that he seems to me that we
have to keep in mind as well I don't
want to use the great game analogy at
all um but I do want to i guess respond
a little bit to both what Steve and and
said again sort of trying to emphasize
some of the differences domestically I
mean first of all it's it's not just oil
prices it can't just be high oil prices
that are driving the obsolescent Gargan
or resource nationalism or this this
host government tendency to renege on on
contracts on contractual terms because
this has happened extensively in
Kazakhstan and not so much and
Azerbaijan it's happened very little in
Azerbaijan a comparison with Kazakhstan
an awesome comparison of what one would
expect and I think that has a lot to do
with what I said before about there
being very different types of foreign
investors we can't lump them all
together in one category either and
there's been a difference in terms of
learning effects or learning abilities
let's say among foreign investors and
their ability to for example form
consorcio and use those consort
to exert pressure on the government
against renege on contracts but also to
sort of insulate themselves from these
types of strategies by by a sort of what
we would say in political science
solving the collective action problem or
uniting together and being sort of a
forming a unified front against
government incursions on their
contractual terms so we've seen that
happen successfully in Azerbaijan and
not so much in Kazakhstan I think that
that's had an impact on the types of
influence that the foreign investors
have had on the type of spending that's
been done in Azerbaijan versus
Kazakhstan you've seen more poverty
alleviation for example and Azerbaijan
coming directly from oil revenue than
you have in Kazakhstan so I mean they're
sort of there's these different outcomes
and effects that as I said Kazakhstan
has saved more of the money which has
helped it through the recovery but it's
also spent less on things that one might
are you are public goods like
alleviating poverty and the reason why I
Azerbaijan has spent more money on not
only poverty alleviation but also local
economic development is because that's
been part of BP's mantra right with its
corporate social responsibility agenda
so there has been a difference and you
see that on on the ground the other
thing I'll say is that I'm curious you
know who these proxies are through which
we've been playing the great game in
Central Asia and maybe so you can say a
little bit more about that i mean i
thought that going back to the early
1990s that the the perfect proxies if
you will would be the international oil
companies and i haven't really seen the
u.s. trying to get the international oil
companies to mean why hasn't chevron
been more like BP why isn't chevron and
kazakhstan been more like BP right why
hasn't the u.s. tried to utilize chevron
or to try to encourage chevron it's been
very recent that Chevron's kind of
signed on very reluctantly signed on to
a CSR you know why is that why isn't the
u.s. been more effective about doing
that and going forward why is the u.s.
doing that engaging more the
international oil companies and
promoting CSR or they're promoting their
commitment to let's say CSR
the oil guy I don't know all the
acronyms reporters I did want to say a
couple things one I think that that the
region has has suffered relatively less
of the resource curse than other parts
of the world I thought I think I think
that Pauline found the same thing and
and so money is trickling down there is
the creation of middle classes in Asura
by John and in Kazakhstan my wife is
from Kazakhstan I know this from the
inside uh you know her family is wealthy
or not because of me okay all right then
regarding the contracts the history of
oil you know read the prize the history
of oil is broken contracts renegotiated
contracts I think if you know the oil
companies price in or they if they're
not pricing and then they you know
they're not being wise that the contract
that they are negotiating may change
over time and probably will change over
time so I don't have anything to say
that Kazakhstan has changed the
contracts so what me that this this is
exactly what happens in the business
this is why smart oilman including ed
used to say this when he was working for
for chevron was that you have to a lot
of times negotiate if you're the oil
company for both sides you have to think
ahead how do I make this contract stable
over a long period of time that means if
you that means not trying to catch the
other guy making a fatal mistake it
means hey telling the other side you're
making a fatal mistake let's not put
that that claws into the
contract and then I just wanted to say
one thing about Uzbekistan you know I
lived in was Becca Stan for two years I
followed it for a long time karima has
always trotted out somehow this place
confounding everyone the IMF and and so
on every year manages to show that it is
grown I challenge you know the the the
folks who watch Uzbekistan closely you
know this is one of those cases are you
going to believe me or your lying eyes
uzbekistan is not growing look look at
the condition the progressively
deteriorating living conditions of this
state and I know the there someone needs
to look under the hood then the
conventional way of evaluating the
wealth and the GDP of a nation does not
work with Uzbekistan could I ask
questions to come up to the microphone
and identify yourselves and confine
yourself as two questions please hi it's
me maria burger and i'm back and i love
the presentations on the oil I were not
those bags oh no I oh I know but I
worked in muscat oman with shale oil and
its petroleum development oman but
she'll had the management and that was
when oil was ten dollars a barrel and it
was a really sad situation for shell at
that time but i learned a lot working as
a corporate trainer in the exploration
asset and the thing i wanted to ask was
now you mentioned pauline private
foreign ownership and my question is
hooked to something else what does the
nation get out of that and also who is
going to own the reward
if a company is given a concession to
drill what happens then they strike oil
they start distributing they refine or
send it to the refinery what percentage
will they own we collect some quite will
collect some questions okay well hi my
name is gonna be entered by I'm teaching
here at Columbia University history
Central Asian history and tradition
history Islam and so on suppose I'm
originally from Kazakhstan and they'll
try to you know establish this link as
far as I can with the Central Asian so
to speak a representation which was
mentioned here missing link with Central
Asia well anyway in time to fill a gap
so to speak in addressing Central Asian
issues from these presentations from the
presentations in on the panel preceding
panel I had the impression and really
cant cannot help having that impression
the center of the centrality of Central
Asia emerges in the first place as a
very very you know interesting place
from the Western geo political point of
view so resources energy security and so
forth and it looks to me also that this
problem with ambiguity with this concept
of great game precisely appears here is
a consequence of the lacking some very
important part of the Central Asian
classical Central Asian great game which
is Imperial ethnographers well I'm as
you know as a person who is teaching
history of central asia i am indeed
asking and very wondering about about
this study area studies in the rest o in
particularly in the u.s. addressing
these local traditions histories
whatever you know identities and so on
so forth how much is this
you know in an issue on the American
agenda when the u.s. tries to bring
Central Asia into its focus and
especially I'm wondering about you need
this energy oil money gas money how it's
going to be spent not only in central
she itself in those agents and
Republic's but especially in the US and
how the government is going to address
this this I in my opinion very missing
link because again without the
understanding of those local networks
which have been established historically
you cannot understand why the US money
is gay is going you know is being
squandered why this aids is in fact
produces quite absolutely unexpected
consequences without understanding those
tribal identities and how this identity
see no tribal networks and how all this
you know local ecology so to speak how
they walk it is very difficult simply to
add to give money and expect the distant
relations now in merchants new nation
states especially Afghanistan in my
opinion it's quite a very striking
example then in the West people try in
special politician start to present it
country as a nation you know kind of
developing sirens nation set which is
absolutely not the case we have this
tribal very very you know divided
countries between these special tribal
groups and again it seems like the
government is not taking into
consideration this kind of now feudal
remnants or so you know if you ll pass
which had to be somehow now addressed in
terms of democracy in terms of now
emerging striving liberal countries and
so forth it's a very very rosy a picture
which the US tries to you know paint or
tries to see into censorship countries
but the reality is quite it's tough it's
very very hard even to others you know
taking the Central Asian governments so
I know you have a tremendous amount to
say on the subject but maybe you could
save some of it for the break okay could
you do okay thank you very much and
jenica ly think will be the last
question in this group and Peter if
you'd wait Jenna kradin a lawyer and a
Columbia University are taking Ed's a
great game and Steve's weren't a
company's playing a great game of their
own maybe last century game and entering
into agreements and medley all
agreements are different that we're too
good to be true in other words take the
stabilization clauses and therefore
forecasted to have I don't call it
economic nationalism in the country's
just ironing out the differences that
should be ironed out that should have
been thought in the beginning so in
other words weren't they playing a great
game that's continuing and we're having
the consequences a specific question for
Pauline and not being quite provocative
but being provocative is csr quite
frankly not a whitewash the way the oil
companies are playing it take BP as one
example hello Peter Senate one of the
computer could you could you hold for
the next group of three let's let people
answer just wait you know I'm not
telling you not to stay at the
microphone but I think there's a lot to
answer let me just go quickly over many
of the interesting questions one of the
obsolescent bargain I'm not accusing
countries or doing anything devious I
just think saying that this is a
addition that the industry has had to
live with throughout its history uh you
know do we do the same mrs. Thatcher's
government has a resource rent tax we
have windfall profits tax when oil
prices went up we just we do the same
thing in our country only fire lawyers
so so it is it's just the way it is
Janek if the company's new that oil
prices were going to be higher than
during twenty dollars maybe they should
have been had more foresight but that's
not what companies do they negotiate
under the conditions of the time and
then when things get better there's a
fight food fight over who grabs the
uplift in economic value and and
generally after your investments are
sunk countries are in half the upper
hand rather than the companies
themselves on CSR as you can tell by now
and I'm not a social scientists in n and
I tend to look into the details of the
the specific conditions of every project
and BP is just in a very different
position in a IOC as the operator a
chevron is in the joint venture with the
government company so so you all
companies can't do things in spite of
the host government it has to do things
with the host government and arguably
when you have a development that's on
shore in the tre o plus a lot more
benefits should go to the RR oblast then
to marble buildings in Astana and our
mati I accept that point but you have to
do it with the government you can't do
it in spite of the government and when
you are in Azerbaijan you have an
offshore concession where there is no
community around it and you've got a
refugee population that is a huge
percentage of your country objectively
you have different conditions and the
government's policy towards meeting
those needs are different on the
question of government take on
as a general rule the Gulf host
government takes a huge amount of the
actual revenue probably a good rule of
thumb would be 85 15 they're all
companies get fifteen percent the host
government get eighty-five percent of
the ultimate value in 10 G's when we
calculated it was more like a t20
because the risks geologic political
risks were different but the issue is
more complicated than that is when do
you get your payback now we're at what
period over 40 years when to the
government ultimately get that 85 eighty
percent of the value is it all at the
end when the companies no longer have
any risks or is it a balanced deal for
everyone over a 40-year life of the
contract but the government gets the
Lord at the lion's share of of the
ultimate revenue I think I did a great
job of answering the questions I'll just
add a little bit the the issue of
private foreign ownership and sort of
the documentation of that as an
ownership structure is not something
that's widely used but something that
that I in particular use and the idea
here is that it's concessionary based
contracts in which the the rights to
develop the sector is actually sold off
to foreign investors right so the
subsoil rights are still the
government's but the right to develop
and exploit the the resource is these
are the concessionary contracts go back
to the early 1900s they were the most
common form of development energy sector
development in the 1900s and they're
sort of making a comeback they have been
making a comeback since the 1990s also
contrary expectations what the nation
gets out of it and why kazakhstan in
particular but countries in general
opted for this particular type of
ownership structure is because they get
their huge upfront payoffs in the form
of big royalties right so you can get a
lot of cash up front you also get cash
over time right and that will differ as
I'd said by the contract and by the
percentages and those vary by contract
but you get a huge upfront royalty in
the payoff of the licenses and so that's
something that if you're if you're like
Kazakhstan and you're desperate for
quick cash early on you go with this
type of it's one of the reasons why you
go with this type of of ownership
structure and there
examples of what as well throughout
throughout the world of you know other
countries adopting this this ownership
structure is csr just a whitewash I'm
not exactly sure what you mean by a
whitewash but csr is widely vilified and
and there's lots of you know joking and
jeering about it snickering probably
maybe in the back of this room when I
was speaking I don't know I used to
myself sort of be one of these big
skeptics but i actually have seen not
just in the former Soviet cases and
Azerbaijan in particular but also in
places in Latin America like Peru where
companies actually do have a real
commitment to corporate social
responsibility that is to making sure
that the money they spend they can't do
anything about the government really
right they can do two things right they
can increase transparency about the
money they give the government right
which is not a small thing for the can't
necessarily increase accountability of
the population over that money rip they
can increase the transparency by making
their contracts public and be pieces
done that in Azerbaijan right you don't
see that in chin in Kazakhstan right the
contracts are all secret although
everybody knows what every else is
paying and the other thing that they can
do is they can ensure that the spending
that they do again not the government so
much but the spending that they do is
then in such a way to maximize social
game right and the way that that's done
again in parts of Latin America as well
as in Azerbaijan is through poverty
alleviation and local business
development I think it's a real thing
right again you could ask the you know
pose the type of counterfactual that Tim
fry pose last panel what if you know
what if BP didn't care right maybe if it
only cares this much and you think it
should cared this much what if it didn't
care at all what if it did behave more
like Chevron sorry it got exactly what
would things have what would things look
like well they would look a lot worse
right because the answer by Johnny
government would be in charge of the
spending not just what so car reaps but
also what the foreign investors are
spending because foreign investors are
spending their own money in addition to
the money they're giving the government
right so it's not just about what
they're paying off in contractual terms
but they're doing so this additional
spending some of its by contract and
some of its voluntary right in addition
to what they are required to spend in
their contract on local development and
it has real effects
and the populations the local
populations would tell you it has it has
real effects I take it very different
position than Chevron and Carlos and
that's precisely my point they're in
different positions because I have
different forms of ownership structure
that's enabled a company like BP that
does care about csr maybe not the United
States but in Azerbaijan to to actually
implement that those policies and BP and
the consortium members of a IOC in
Azerbaijan have also faced let's say
attempts by the Azerbaijani government
to change the terms of their contract
they faced attempts by the Azerbaijani
government change the way they do
they're spending their voluntary
spending and they resisted that right so
it's not that they haven't faced them it
says they've resisted them that's right
that all host governments want to renege
on contracts of course they do that's
that's that's the right that perfectly
makes sense but some foreign investors
are better about resisting those
encroachments than others well I just
want to say thanks to goulart for how
they mentioned history and I think that
we all know that the Harriman institute
and the davis center would dearly love
to spend more time teaching people
Central Asian history and the more
resources people would like to donate to
that to that great the more they'd be
happy to date them yes I think we have
our last three questionnaires at the
microphone Peter Senate the elephant in
the room on the energy panel has to be
the lack of talk about the hydroelectric
station building and you know this has
become such a key foreign policy part of
the relations between Kyrgyzstan with
Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan with is Becca Stan
and Tajikistan with Uzbekistan across
Turkmenistan is a down the road but that
said I thought a very interesting
polling Jones long when you emphasize
that this practice on is increasing its
exports in gas and maybe perhaps oil and
I have to remember back to that day in
may 2005 on the square in on Dijon that
that was one of the key issues that was
brought up which was the lack of heating
that previous winter
and the situation of a country exporting
and increasing its exports at the same
time it cannot satisfy the domestic
needs and that also then leads to a
question for Edward Chow and that is
with with this error of the pipelines
now being so well developed throughout
especially Kazakhstan but do you see an
error now where we will see some use of
further pipeline building to encourage
domestic use good afternoon my name is
Gao herb de galiba I'm they PhD visiting
scholars here at Columbia I'm advised by
the professor but Professor Jenna crate
and so I'm pulling up from the question
about csr in the Caspian region and I
also wanted to marry it to that the
great game continues thing my question
here is more sort of a provocative
monologue some point to one of course of
course so basically if we're talking
that the great game continues and we
also heard the epilogue of the previous
section that we're actually talking
about the pretty chinese central asia
this time this year saw by the Western
companies really that important now if
CNPC is mostly gaining all the projects
biggest stakes by plants in Kazakhstan
with where I come from originally of
course and really what I'm saying
probably US has already lost that game
in a sense and that is why it's not that
committed to csr at all and if we speak
of BP of course that old for on planes
issues I'd say that probably be p be in
the UK or sort of UK US corporation we
know that UK is a champion in csr so
probably that was the case in nineties
but now thank you very much
hi nick cavalio mwambie is doing here a
graduate student at call me excuse me I
won't also on the follow up on the
hydropower question and if the panel
could talk a little bit too maybe the
potential conflicts that can arise
because water rights are extremely
controversial also the potential
developments as far as hydro power in
the region and how that will have an
effect maybe 20 30 years on the road
thanks i think by default and the 1's
talk about hydroponics yeah i think this
is it this is a great point and you're
right that it's um it's a it's a diff t
seat of the panel and that's largely I
think my fault since I said I was that
was going to focus on domestic issues as
Alex raised the thing in the last panel
this is the issue over water and control
of water is that is a is a big one and
it's one that has been quite thorny
there's been lots of actually work
effort than on trying to get regional
cooperation over water rights and it has
not come to fruition this is since the
early 1990s and this is the the
underlying issue when it comes to
hydroelectricity of course because how
do you generate electricity from water
and you have the upstream right Perry
ends with the downstream and the fight
over that the sort of cure deeds in
Tajikistan the one hand and uzbekistan
turkmenistan the other hand I don't have
any answers except sit for you know
whether that's going to be resolved or
how it's going to be resolved I don't
think so anytime soon i mean what i will
say is that um energy demand internal
energy demand is on the on the rise
within Central Asia particularly in
Uzbekistan and Kazakhstan ie the
economy's they're growing right and I
take the point that was made earlier I
forget by home about the funny it was
Steve about the the funny math that use
Becca Stanny government does Anna
statistics and we can talk about that
more later I've become more convinced in
recent numbers and I have it in the past
partly because I've been doing some work
with the IMF but regardless you know
they're they're they're rising energy
demands and right now those demands are
met and Kazakhstan mostly through coal
and is Uzbekistani mostly through gas
but that's going to change and that's
going to shift over time and as Peter
pointed out rightly different regions
have
for dependence on different types of
energy to generate our energy sources to
generate their electricity use but as
you see demand rise if particularly the
growing economies of Central Asia this
is become a bigger problem in a bigger
issue not a smaller one it's not going
to go away so it's something that still
needs to be addressed but I don't have
any answers for how to how to go about
addressing it I just wanted to say one
thing about the stability of the
contracts it's just one one little
detail that regards oz or by John the
stability of that of that contract it
has not been renegotiated but but just
carrying on from what from genex comment
the one piece of that contract that
isn't stable is the Georgia piece and
just as a flag for everyone here don't
be surprised sometime down the road in
the coming years that a IOC is forced to
to agree to new terms on the Georgia
piece of the contract because it really
is a unequal unequal terms ang anak
might just help them do that just
quickly I don't really think that the
pertinent question is hydroelectricity I
think the pertinent question is water
use and water rights because you have to
secure their situation of the five
countries in Central Asia where two
countries have all the water and the
other three countries have all the oil
and gas right and and and hydro
electricity projects are tremendously
capital intensive projects so who are
you going to sell the electricity to
write you didn't notice you can't do it
on Tajikistan and Kyrgyzstan demand they
don't become bankable projects so
yourself you want to sell the
electricity to countries that are much
more interested in using the water for
irrigation for agriculture then actually
importing electricity so you've got a
conundrum that's very difficult it seems
to me
to resolve on the issue of domestic use
of power and electricity the problem is
how do you develop a distribution system
if the commodity is giving out as a
social good rather than as a economic
good that population have to pay for and
and that's a part of the problem of
having authoritarian regimes where if
you have weak legitimacy is that you
know one of the things that they had to
deliver to a place to get cold is Elise
Walt right if we can't do that then
their political legitimacy is even worse
Oh their ability to do pricing reform
for both power and gas is rather limited
and and that's one of the barriers from
the economic point of view I would not
overestimate Chinese oil companies in in
Central Asia you add up the number of
announcements you acted it may seem very
impressive but you look at who's
managing the big oil fields it's BP it's
Chevron is the kashagan consortium you
look at the reserve life of those fields
versus all the a few hundred million
barrels reserves that the Chinese
companies are buying up at a very hot
steep price and they don't amount to
very much so but no sorry I would not
say that the Western company influenced
today at this point or you maybe even
into the next 5-10 years is diminished
my point is different you know if a
Western company get an onshore gas
license in Turkmenistan they would be
perfectly happy to ship their gas screw
the Chinese pipeline that was pre built
and paid for by the Chinese to market
and but the question is is that
consistent with us national interest and
I would submit to you that Steve is
right that that is entirely consistent
with us national interest I remember a
conversation with a American ambassador
in Astana a number of years ago asking
him what's the
in position before the pipelines were
built on pipelines to China and his
response was depends on whether you're
talking about oil or gas I submit to you
it should not make a difference at all
thank you please join me in thanking the
panelists or very leaded